- [Instructor] So let's
see if we can try to factor
the following expression completely.
So factor this completely,
pause the video and have a go at that.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the way that I like to think about it,
I first try to see is
there any common factor
to all the terms, and I
try to find the greatest
of the common factor,
possible common factors
to all of the terms.
So let's see, they're
all divisible by two,
so two would be a common factor,
but let's see, they're
also all divisible by four,
four is divisible by four,
eight is divisible by four,
12 is divisible by four,
and that looks like the
greatest common factor.
They're not all divisible by x,
so I can't throw an x in there.
So what I wanna do is factor out a four.
So I could re-write this as four times,
now what would it be, four times what?
Well if I factor a four
out of four x squared,
I'm just going to be
left with an x squared.
If I factor a four out
of negative eight x,
negative eight x divided
by four is negative two,
so I'm going to have negative two x.
And if I factor a four out of negative 12,
negative 12 divided by
four is negative three.
Now am I done factoring?
Well it looks like I
could factor this thing
a little bit more.
Can I think of two numbers
that add up to negative two,
and when I multiply it
I get negative three,
since when I multiply
I get a negative value,
one of the 'em is going to be positive
and one of 'em is going to be negative.
I can think about it this way.
A plus B is equal to negative two,
A times B needs to be
equal to negative three.
So let's see, A could be
equal to negative three
and B could be equal to one
because negative three
plus one is negative two,
and negative three times
one is negative three.
So I could re-write all of this
as four times x plus negative three,
or I could just write
that as x minus three,
times x plus one, x plus one.
And now I have actually
factored this completely.
Let's do another example.
So let's say that we had the expression
negative three x squared
plus 21 x minus 30.
Pause the video and see if you
can factor this completely.
All right now let's do this together.
So what would be the
greatest common factor?
So let's see, they're
all divisible by three,
so you could factor out a three.
Let's see what happens if
you factor out a three.
This is the same thing as three times,
well negative three x squared divided
by three is negative x squared,
21 x divided by three is
seven x, so plus seven x,
and then negative 30 divided
by three is negative 10.
You could do it this way,
but having this negative
out on the x squared term
still makes it a little bit confusing
on how you would factor this further.
You can do it, but it still takes
a little bit more of a mental load.
So instead of just factoring out a three,
let's factor out a negative three.
So we could write it this way.
If we factor out a negative
three, what does that become?
Well then if you factor
out a negative three out
of this term, you're just
left with an x squared.
If you factor out a negative
three from this term,
21 divided by negative
three is negative seven x.
And if you factor out a negative
three out of negative 30,
you're left with a
positive 10, positive 10.
And now let's see if we
can factor this thing
a little bit more.
Can I think of two numbers
where if I were to add them
I get to negative seven,
and if I were to multiply
them, I get to 10?
And let's see, they'd
have to have the same sign
'cause their product is positive.
So let's see A could be
equal to negative five,
and then B is equal to negative two.
So I can re-write this
whole thing as equal
to negative three times
x plus negative five,
which is the same thing as x minus five,
times x plus negative two,
which is the same thing as x minus two.
And now we have factored completely.